so what we need to do is try and take
another approach so to do that to help
you see what approach will help I'd love
you to I need more space I need to add a
new line in for myself a new page
I'd love you to draw a set of axes for
me and just for the sake of illustration
this set of axes probably if you put it
in the first quadrant I think should be
fine we don't need the whole thing
we actually could put this set of axes
anywhere we liked but um just for the
sake of illustration
what I'm going to do is I'm I know I'm
just drawing this in 2D but uh you can
still imagine this as a slice of 3D
space right so everything that I'm about
to reason through right now is something
that will still be true in three
dimensions even though I've only drawn
two of them okay and what I want to do
is uh if I draw a line let's let's draw
a line off like this and maybe you can
join me in putting some arbitrary line
in this um in this space that I have
conceived
and what I want to imagine is some point
on this line let's call it P
and then I want to imagine you know what
we want to create this line is again an
infinite set of points I accidentally
created an infinite set of lines which
is not really what I wanted right so I
want to have an infinite set of points
on this line and for reasons that I
don't really understand
um by by convention we tend to call
lines in 3D space
um R so it's it's like an r with a with
a vector light underneath it
um I think it's a little bit like why we
call gradient M some tradition started
somewhere somewhere along the way and
then we just kind of kept with it okay
so I've got my line r and I want to find
a bunch of points on this line r that
would constitute the line if I String
them all together okay so for example if
I put a couple of markers here and what
I'm going to try and do is put these at
sort of some even spacings okay so if I
put in and let's just do it one a bit
further along okay if I put in some
points here let's call them a b and this
one's C over here and then for good
measure
let's put some on the other side as well
like so okay
now if I I Define for myself a way to
get from the origin up to P so if I go
from from the origin up to P so this
Vector over here
okay uh let's call this Vector U
I can get from o to p and then I can get
from P to any spot along this line r by
thinking about uh I guess you may call
it a unit Vector along this line right
let me say that again a unit Vector
along this line can be my um my
mechanism or my tool for getting to any
point on the line that's kind of why we
have unit vectors right it just gives
you the right direction and then you can
go however many units you need okay so
because it's the first point let's just
call this Vector here from P to a let's
call that the unit Vector I'm going to
call it V because I had a u before this
is V
so if I said okay what is what is the
vector a
um O A how would I say that in terms of
my use and my V's this is not a
rhetorical question how do I String
together other vectors Sean
fantastic just U plus v
and now because what I've done is tried
to evenly space what's going on right if
I wanted to go instead of going to a if
I wanted to go to B
I wouldn't just say Okay U plus a single
lot of V V's my my unit then I just need
to go another one of those along right
because you can see that these are these
are I've drawn them to be the same right
that's another V there so therefore I
could say that OB would be uh Ryan do
you want to tell us what it is
yep U Plus 2v
and I could find I can I can express any
point on the line r in this way right if
I went to OC because of the way that
I've drawn it you might be able to tell
it's like well there's four of those
units okay
now looking on the other side I've got
OD and I've got OE even though they're
in an opposite direction there's still a
way to use V the unit Vector to work out
a way to get there or a way to express
the way there what would I do
yeah
fantastic or you could think of it as U
plus
uh negative one times V because it's
just the opposite direction but that is
of course the same as taking it away and
then for OE because I've gone one more
it's like well this is you take away 2v
okay
now what I want to do here is I can I
can generalize this right can you see
what's the same what all the points on
line are share and what's different
right uh tell me what's the same
for you so you is always there okay so
um what I'm doing is I'm generalizing
here
so U is always there out the front and
then what's different what varies
yeah it's just how how many V's do you
have or I actually should say how much
of V do you have because I've picked
these easy integer values but there's
nothing stopping you from picking some
arbitrary proportion of V so long as
it's V you're going to get the direction
right yeah and then if you say half of V
or 0.1 of V or 1000 V you're still going
to be somewhere on R right so to sort of
capitalize on that we would say there's
some uh
uh constant coefficient uh sorry a
variable coefficient of V so by
convention again I don't know why it's
this we use the Greek letter Lambda so
Lambda is some kind of real number it's
it's not a vector
but this is the vector equation of a
line
now uh this this is it this is the
actual equation that we were searching
for before we were using x's and y's and
Z's but if we use Vector notation we can
actually Express this line unambiguously
and not accidentally end up with a plane
okay so what you've created over here
I'll Zoom back in sorry is um we have a
technical term for this this is called
not just the equation of a line but the
vector equation of a line because we've
used the U and the V there
to get away from this problem of the
Cartesian equation accidentally giving
us a plane instead of a line okay
now uh I I before we have a go and an
actual question with this I do want to
sort of number one generalize this just
a little bit more because even though
this is very general you can be anything
V can be anything there's a couple other
things I want to point out and then I
want to connect this to some other
knowledge that you have uh well what we
start off the lesson with Okay so let's
generalize this a little bit further
what I've done is I've called it unv
right but equally you could say that
this line r
can be stated as go from o to a that was
that was what we abbreviated as you and
then we said uh add some uh multiple of
a b so a b was like along the line okay
does that make sense
now this is not the only way to say R
there's actually many alternatives for
how we can say R so you know how we
talked about the fact that uh going back
over here
um there are many many different ways to
say the equation of a line in 2D well
there's many many ways infinitely many
ways to say an equation in three
dimensions right and in fact I wonder if
you can see some of them right for
example
I went from o and I said
um uh let's go to P right so in fact I
did op but now I've done o a can't I go
to any point on the line like I could
have said uh maybe go to OB instead and
then still add on that same direction
can you see that would still be the same
line different equation but I'm still
getting onto the line and then going in
the correct direction to take me off
into Infinity yeah
or I could have said uh go to that same
point
and instead of saying a b be the vector
what other Vector could I have chosen
okay yep so I could have expanded that
out a b in terms of how I actually got
there it's components
um alternatively like why why did I pick
a and b or p and a as the unit Vector I
didn't I didn't have to anything along R
any two points will Define a unit Vector
quote unquote right so therefore I could
have made it like say for example p d
that's still going in a Direction that's
a long R does that make sense so you can
see that there are many different valid
equations when you go to do the
exercises and you have a look at the
answers the answer might not match the
vector equation of a line that you have
but it might be equivalent so you need
to really watch for that it's not quite
so obvious um when it is like if I gave
you
y equals 3x minus 5 and then you looked
at the the answer in the textbook and it
was like oh they've written 3x minus y
minus 5 equals zero it's it's fairly
routine to see that those two are the
same you just have to rearrange right
and make y the subject if you're going
from the bottom one to the top but it's
it's not quite so straightforward when
you get Vector equations of lines
because they can often look quite
different and still be the same thing
okay so just watch out for that
now one last point before we do an
example question uh I I kind of LED you
down a bit of a rabbit hole right I was
like oh look 2D to 3D 2D to 3D it all
follows the pattern right I wonder
though if any of you remember
there's a notable recent example we did
it last week of where uh going from 2D
to 3D isn't just add a z in right do you
remember it's actually on the page I
just haven't written it in the
appropriate form which one of these
results
these ones here
actually has a version where you don't
just add on Zed does anyone remember
which one
yeah very good so the dot product if I
write it another way and let's just
review that right okay I've got space
here
the dot product we noticed that if you
just think about the magnitudes of the
two vectors
and then the angle between the two
vectors uh it's it's exactly the same in
three dimensions as it is in two right
now in fact if you look closely at these
Vector equations of lines maybe if you
squint really hard and don't worry I'm
going to show you exactly how it works
you'll be able to see how there's a way
in which this is exactly the same in
three dimensions as it is in two
Dimensions it's just we made the wrong
comparison okay so here's the way I'm
going to State it one more time uh yeah
I'll have no space here above the
example let's write this R equals U plus
Lambda V okay let me give some names on
top of these things and try and
highlight what's going on here okay
the first thing are that is the line
itself so it's it's slightly confusing
to me why we use exactly the same Vector
notation even though a line as we
pointed out before is not a vector
because it goes for Infinity if you want
to think of a parallel to this because
mathematicians we can be annoying
sometimes think about function notation
right function notation f of x you know
that that doesn't mean
F times x but it's it's literally
exactly the same notation right so it
just kind of depends on context sorry
about that so R is the line
you we give it a special name we call
this the position Vector now I wonder if
you can see why it gets that name
remember what is you doing let's let's
go back to this diagram up here U is the
vector that gets me onto the line gets
me onto the line right so it positions
you in 3D space so that you are on the
line and now you can just say well which
which way should I be facing I'm in the
right spot I'm on the line I'm in
position but which which way should I be
looking to go in Infinity right and so
that's why this last part here uh wrong
color this last part here V is not a
position Vector it's what we call the
Direction vector because it tells you
which way the line is facing
uh what way are you looking in order to
get this so position Vector gets you on
the line
and then Direction Vector tells you
which way to go okay
now this this form highlighting it this
way that you can think of a line as do
the first thing you should do is is go
some number of units to get on the line
and then the second thing you should do
is just face in a particular direction
to tell you where to go right there is a
form
of lines in two Dimensions that does
exactly this we've just not really
thought about it in those terms right
um usually we would say that a line is y
equals something right
what would be the equivalent of a
direction vector
for a line in two Dimensions the
direction Vector is which way is it
going right what's the closest idea that
we have to that in two dimensions
didn't quite catch it
yeah very good it's it's the gradient
gradient tells you which way the line is
going if you if I told you gradient of a
half you you have a picture in your mind
for which way that's going if I told you
gradient negative three you now have a
direction for that right so in other
words that's like the m x right except
it's the which part of the MX is the
quote unquote Direction it's the it's
the M which is the gradient right
so this m which we call gradient in two
dimensions
it's equivalent to Direction
okay we've already said that this Y part
over here is just a name for the line
what's the part that's missing which
part haven't I written
yeah the constant that gets me on the
line now the form of writing the line
that we usually use is MX
plus b right but I've written the b in
the front to parallel it with the
position Vector up above there right so
the uh the y-intercept
The Intercept here is equivalent to
position yourself on the line so this
intercept
is really the same
as the position
okay
so I hope you can see that much like
with the dot product if you think about
it in the same way it's like oh lines in
2D lines in 3D they really are exactly
the same it's just that we have to use
the right form to get there